dada la ecuación
la x a la n dónde x es mayor que 0 y m
es menor que cero cuando los siguientes
enunciados es válido para valores reales
de y bueno nos dicen que x es mayor que
0 x mayor que 0 y nos dicen que n es
menor que ser el exponente aquí a ser
negativo es menor que cero pero la base
es positiva y quizás su primera reacción
sea pensar que si el exponente es
negativo ya será negativa pero no es así
un exponente negativo es lo opuesto a un
exponente positivo es decir si yo tengo
y igual a x a la n esto va a ser igual a
/ x a la menos n y si n es menor que
cero aquí abajo será mayor que cero así
que no importa que el número negativo
haya aquí especialmente teniendo la base
positiva siempre tendremos un número
mayor que cero y mientras más grande sea
el exponente más pequeña será la
fracción por ejemplo 1 / x a la
centésima potencia será una fracción muy
pequeñita que se podrá aproximar a 0
pero que siempre será una cantidad
positiva mayor a 0 y no igual así que la
respuesta va a ser nuestra opción a y es
mayor que 0 resolvamos el siguiente
problema si x es un número real cuál
escribe mejor los valores para los
cuales la desigualdad raíz de x mayor a
0 es verdadera bueno asumiendo que
estamos trabajando con números reales
sino con imaginarios aquí nos preguntan
cuál es el dominio qué valores de x
ponemos aquí de manera que esto se
cumpla vamos a escribirlo aquí x
cuadrada igual a raíz de equis si yo
hago el cuadrado en ambos lados de esta
ecuación me va a quedar aquí x a la
cuarta igual a x si x es igual a 1 aquí
lo sustituyó x 1 a la cuarta igual a 1
así que uno es igual a 1 también
funcionaría para x igual a 0 pero
asumiendo que no vamos a dividir esto
entre x esto lo vimos entre x esto lo
dividimos entre x y nos queda x cúbica
igual a 1 y el único valor hasta donde
yo sé donde se cumpliría esto es con x
igual a 1 y viendo las opciones pues la
opción que es verdadera es que el
enunciado es verdadero cuando x es igual
a 0
no podemos tener x negativas en raíces
cuadradas y el enunciado si se cumple
para x igual a cero y x igual a un ok
pasamos al siguiente problema el número
63 alfredo quiere crear diferentes
nombres de pantalla de siete caracteres
él quiere hacer combinaciones usando las
tres primeras letras de su nombre alfa
seguido de cuatro dígitos
1987 que es el año de su nacimiento
cuántos nombres de pantalla diferentes
puede crear de esta manera pensemos en
cada uno de los lugares por carácter o
dígito de ese nombre de pantalla nos
dicen que son siete caracteres así que
vamos a escribir uno dos tres cuatro
cinco
seis y
muy bien nos dicen que en los primeros
tres lugares van a ser combinaciones de
las letras de su nombre así que cuántas
opciones tenemos para el primer lugar
bueno vamos a tener disponibles tres
letras a elegir así que vamos a tener
tres opciones una vez elegida la opción
acá guardas opciones nos quedan para el
segundo lugar pues estas tres una ya
estará ocupada así que nos van a quedar
dos opciones de las letras del nombre
para el tercer lugar una vez que ya
seleccionamos el segundo lugar pues no
nos va a quedar la letras sobrantes
vamos a tener nada más una opción ahora
en estos cuatro lugares van a estar los
dígitos del año de nacimiento de alfredo
cuántos lugares tenemos para este cuarto
lugar pues podemos elegir cualquiera de
estos cuatro dígitos así que vamos a
tener cuatro opciones una vez elegida
esta opción cuantos nos van a quedar
para el quinto lugar pues de esas cuatro
opciones pero ya una fue elegida nos van
a quedar 33 opciones para poner en este
quinto lugar y una vez que elegimos cual
va acá pues sólo nos van a quedar
opciones para este sexto lugar y
finalmente para el séptimo lugar nos va
a quedar el dígito sobrante una opción
ok entonces para saber las combinaciones
lo que vamos a hacer es multiplicar
todos estos elementos y ver cuál es el
resultado entonces tenemos 2 por 3 6 6
por unas 6 6 por 4 24
24 por 3
72 24 por 3
72 por 2 es
144 por una nos queda
144 combinaciones posibles con estas
características que es nuestra opción de
144 veamos el siguiente problema
un tren tiene una locomotora siete
vagones diferentes y un campus al final
si la locomotora va al principio y el
cabús al final de cuantas maneras
diferentes se puede ordenar el tren pues
es algo muy similar al problema anterior
pero con menos lugares lo que lo va a
ser más sencillo tenemos aquí está p de
posición y voy a poner esta de de
vagones o de las opciones de vagones que
podemos tener y ya que la locomotora y
el cabús están fijos no van a cambiar de
lugar pues sólo tenemos los siete
opciones o siete lugares de los vagones
diferentes entonces tenemos uno dos tres
cuatro
cinco seis siete posiciones para la
primera posición cuántas opciones
tendremos para colocar aquí de los siete
vagones pues tendremos las siete
opciones porque podemos elegir
cualquiera de ellos una vez he elegido
una opción acá para el segundo lugar nos
quedarán seis opciones disponibles ya
que elegimos una pared en segundo lugar
pues vamos a restarle a este 6 11 nos
van a quedar cinco opciones para el
tercer lugar para el cuarto lugar
tendremos cuatro opciones para el quinto
lugar tenemos tres para el sexto lugar
tendremos dos opciones y finalmente el
séptimo lugar tendrá lo que nos sobró
una opción de wagon y hacemos lo mismo
que en el anterior vamos a multiplicar
todas estas opciones entre sí para ver
cuáles son las posibles combinaciones 1
por 2 2 2 por 3 6 6 por 4
24 24 por 5 120 120 por 6 1
720 720 por 7 aquí sí voy a tener que
hacer una operación a un lado
720 por 7
7 por 0 0 7 por 2 14 llevó 17 por 7 49 y
150 5 mil 40
combinaciones posibles que es de
nuestras opciones la opción a ok veamos
el último problema de este vídeo
wendy y mariana son dos estudiantes que
están entre diez estudiantes que han
aplicado para un viaje a washington dc
dos estudiantes del grupo serán elegidos
aleatoriamente para el viaje cuál es la
probabilidad de que wendy y mariana sean
las dos estudiantes seleccionadas bueno
pensemos en el primer estudiante
seleccionado el primer estudiante
seleccionado y en el segundo estudiante
cuál es la probabilidad de que primero
seleccionen a wendy windy y después a
mariana bueno aquí hay dos maneras de
resolver esto tenemos la opción de que
primero se ha seleccionado when y luego
mariana o tenemos la opción de que
primero sea seleccionada mariana y luego
web y si sumamos ambas probabilidades
tendremos la probabilidad de que
cualquiera de las dos ocurra
en esta primera opción la probabilidad
de winnie es de 1 entre 10 y la
probabilidad de mariana ya que aquí se
seleccionó 1 ya no serían 10 sería 1
entre 9 así que multiplicamos un décimo
por un noveno y nos va a quedar 1 entre
90 en esa segunda combinación bueno la
probabilidad de que sea mariana la
primera estudiante seleccionada es de un
décimo
y la probabilidad de que voy a iniciar
la seleccionada después es un 1 entre 9
lo multiplicamos un décimo por un noveno
igual nos va a dar 1 entre 90 y ahora lo
que tenemos que hacer es sumar ambas
probabilidades para encontrar la
probabilidad total 1 entre 90 más 1
entre 90 va a ser igual a 2 entre 90
y esto lo simplificamos lo dividimos
entre 2 tanto arriba como abajo 2 entre
2 es 190 entre 12 45 y tenemos la
probabilidad de 1 entre
45 que es nuestra opción